hey youtubers it's Charlie so since
Scott Gimple and Robert Kirkman have
both been talking a lot about negan in
season 5 lately I thought it was time to
do a video about my top 10 picks for
actors I think should play the role they
were pretty vague on how and when that
would happen but we can pick apart the
clues as we go along since there is so
much time before the new season starts
feel free to leave suggestions for
future bonus videos in the comments
below until I turn full-time YouTube
creator I can probably only do about one
a week but I'll try to make it like a
regular Thursday or Friday thing be sure
to subscribe to get everything
so let's get started with this negan
what not by asking a really big question
what kind of an actor do we want for the
role negan is without a doubt one of the
worst most casually sadistic people
we've ever read about is there an actor
out there that can pull that off when I
made this top 10 list I tried to think
only of actors the could one hold screen
time with Andrew Lincoln and Norman
Reedus
and two could kind of convey the comedy
of the nican character and at the same
time be incredibly violent as awful as
negan is I always kind of felt like we
were meant to laugh at his cruel jokes
and then feel really awful about it of
course like Robert Kirkman wants you to
treat negan like a sadistic comedian so
all these potential actors have to be
funny imposing super evil without
looking like they're doing an impression
of the Joker so let's get started number
10 paying homage to Robert Kirkman's
comments Jon Hamm everyone asks Kirkman
about negan all the time and in a recent
interview he threw out jon Hamm's name
as a solid choice for the character just
because there's something about physical
resemblance and Jon Hamm can kind of
pull off that really imposing part negan
has those really strong features
jet-black hair and he's super tall just
picture Don Draper really pissed off
with the baseball bat that he just
happened to nicknamed Lucille I think
the other main reason that Kirkman threw
jon Hamm's name out there is that he can
kind of hold back some of that violence
behind his eyes you know without
literally just like punching someone
every times he sees them any actor that
has to play that part will obviously
have to be as crazy as the Joker but be
able to hold it in and Jon Hamm is just
really good at making you afraid of him
just by staring at you
number 9 Henry Rollins there was this
old walking dead Comic Con 2012
we're the artists on the comic book
Charlie Adlard said that negan was
actually based on Henry Rollins both in
his look and level of intensity I
haven't listened to Henry Rollins music
recently but even if you don't know his
music just check him out on sons of
anarchy and as an interesting side note
Henry Rollins also has voice characters
on Batman The Brave and the bold and
Adventure Time number 8 James Purefoy
who's currently on the following he's
done some comic book material before in
Solomon Kane but if he bolt up just a
little bit and got a little more
physical he could totally pull off negan
his villain on the following is just a
little more insidious than negan but it
totally works everyone probably has
their own opinion about how negan is
expressing his version of evil but I
always thought of his alignment is being
lawful evil like he has his own code and
rules that he follows and if you break
them instead of kicking you out of the
group you know he'll just slaughter you
there's just a lot of interesting father
parallels between the negan character
and Rick's character that I feel that
the Purefoy could pull off he could
totally be an evil dad just like you
know say lucius malfoy
before baltimore came along number 7
Patrick Warburton most people know him
as the voice of Joe on Family Guy
but he's essentially a comedic actor
that mostly plays large imposing
characters he'd be perfect for the
comedic aspects of negan like the
endless f-bombs that he drops he's also
really good at using his size to be
scary I really like the idea of negan
having the voice of Joe from Family Guy
but here's a big question that I want
you to answer in the comments what kind
of a voice do you think the comic book
version of negan has you know does he
have a really big voice to match his big
size or is it softer or more
high-pitched personally I just I always
viewed him as having a very deep
imposing voice number six Michael Madsen
he's the perfect mix of crazy and funny
so I had to put him on the list
somewhere but seriously even in real
life he's like Gary Busey crazy he's a
little bit older than I see the
character being and he'd had to get in
better shape but the show does fudge the
way people look sometimes if the actor
is right for the part David Moore see
for example didn't look anything like
the comic book version of the governor
but he was such an amazing actor that it
totally worked I have a feeling that
Madsen is one of those actors that has
to improvise a lot so I think not being
able to stick to the script might be a
problem for him
especially when you're adapting a comic
that's already really good I just don't
think it's a really good idea to change
a lot of the dialog especially if you're
shooting scenes like straight off the
page number five Nicolas Cage another
crazy in real life actor that could
totally pull it off on the show cage
despite some big box-office bombs it's
still relatively sought-after for film
roles so his schedule might prevent him
from doing the series but if negan isn't
featured too often it could totally work
in real life I feel like if you actually
ran into Nicolas Cage on say like a dark
Street in the middle of the night you
might actually mistake him for negan in
real life cuz he just is that crazy
number four Dominic West he'd have to do
with an American accent but I feel like
you really need to see him on the wire
as Jimmy McNulty to really appreciate
how good he is and making you like a
character that's just awful no one
expects you to empathize with negan but
there are moments when we're supposed to
root for him and that's going to be one
of the hardest things for any actor that
plays this role to do I feel like if
Walking Dead wants to be as successful
going forward as it is right now you
know it's one of the most popular cable
shows on TV it's gonna have to have a
villain that you can root for every once
in a while and I think Dominic West can
totally pull that off number three
tamo penikett right now he's doing a
totally awesome job of playing an evil
angel on supernatural most people
probably just remember him though as
helo from Battlestar I've actually
enjoyed him more in the bad guy roles
he's played since Battlestar he's got
the right look for it the right
physicality and as a performer he won't
necessarily say outswing Andrew Lincoln
and Norman Reedus or any of the other
main cast members whenever they have to
share screen time I feel like it works a
lot better whenever your characters are
more equally matched know when it's hard
to tell who the biggest badass is on
screen and in season five it's gonna be
all about the return of badass Rick I
think the thing that's actually gonna
end up making negan seem like this
insurmountable obstacle is gonna be his
gang you know he's just one man so if
Daryl Rick Tyreese and Abraham say
jumped him all at the same time he
totally go down but negan has the
Savior's you know his own evil version
of the survivors the other thing that I
think makes Timo penikett say a more
realistic choice for the role is it is
much more attainable for the show as an
actor as opposed to say like Nicolas
Cage who you know who's been an a-list
actor in this probably way more
expensive and way less available number
two one of my favorite Psychopaths
as Ray Stevenson he was a very very
bloody version of the Punisher
but imagine a cross between that
character and his character from Dexter
both Psychopaths just like negan but you
know much more balanced in terms of the
amount of dialogue and the violence
negan unlike the Punisher has to talk a
lot Stevens got all the same physical
requirements as a lot of those other
choices but he's also just an amazingly
underappreciated actor if you haven't
seen it yet you should totally watch his
season of Dexter it wasn't the last one
I think it was season seven he was
actually one of the best villains that
show ever had and as an added bonus we
know that he can do that over-the-top
Punisher level violence and whether you
love or hate
crazy violence negan is gonna have to go
there at some point based on what Scott
Gimple said negan's first appearance is
gonna be very brief so I think it's
gonna be like season 6 before we see any
major horror montages with him and the
Savior's or maybe as like a season 5
cliffhanger reveal I can totally
understand the producers wanting to wait
to let this dog out of his cage but my
number one pick for negan Bill Paxton
two words hail Hydra seriously what's
the best part of agents of shield right
now
evil Bill Paxton even though the writing
on Kirkman's Walking Dead books is
totally different from the types of
things you see in Marvel books it
totally works just a more sadistic
version of the garrotte character he's
playing right now and one with you know
a lot more f-bombs casually dropped into
conversation sometimes big actors like
Bill Paxton don't want to play villains
and back-to-back roles but if he's been
able to do so much with a c-level
character like Garrett on agents of
shield just think what he could do with
an epic villain like negan on Walking
Dead the thing I like about Bill Paxton
the most is that he makes you enjoy
watching [ __ ] characters and negan is
like the ultimate [ __ ] I think the
really big question that we need to ask
though is is what kind of show is it
gonna be whenever negan does appear
because Scott Campbell has been pretty
clear that season to season the show
completely changes so like season three
Walking Dead is a completely different
show from season four and so on and so
on
negan's character has this really
comedic element to him the show is gonna
have to accommodate and right now
Walking Dead is definitely not full of
laughable moments you know the closest
thing recently was when you got Carl
eating
putting on the roof and that was more a
moment of relief than say like a laugh
out loud funny moment whenever negan
does show up I feel like there's only
gonna be two viable emotional responses
you can either one choose to laugh at
his evil just because he's so over the
top and ridiculous or you can just cry
because what he does is so horrible I
suppose you could try to do both at the
same time though but now it's your turn
let me know who is your favorite choice
to play negan and like I said he's
probably not gonna show up till maybe
like the second half of season 5 and
even then very briefly so what we see of
him in the next year is gonna be very
very little in related news while I work
on my next Walking Dead bonus video be
sure to leave me suggestions for future
topics we have so many more weeks before
season five premieres so there's lots
opportunities and a lot of things we can
talk about right now you can click here
to get my season 5 predictions and you
can click here to watch my finale video
again thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives